We have said many times that the ATF
is the exchange coin for energy in cells,
but in this video we talk about this topic in more detail.
As we will see when we move from ATF to ADP,
or ADP + phosphate group, we have free energy release.
If we look at the system,
the ATF's free energy is here, but once it's gone
hydrolysis and obtain ADP + phosphate group,
the free energy dropped by nearly 30.5 kJ / mol,
delta G is -30.5 kJ / mol.
If you look at Gibbs's free energy videos,
you will know that this value tells us that this is a spontaneous reaction.
Delta G is less than zero,
which means that this reaction will be spontaneous.
When I realized this was the first time I said to myself,
"Once the reaction is spontaneous, why
then all the ATP and all the water
do not turn spontaneously into ADP and do not release energy
in the form of heat or something else? "
The key is that the reaction must climb that hill.
We have this activating energy,
the reaction has to go up,
if there is no enzyme to catalyze it.
Now we will explain why we have this uprising in the path of reaction.
When ATP breaks down, we have
a molecule of water that carries out the hydrolysis.
This is the way people usually imagine hydrolysis.
Although sometimes another molecule may be involved.
But if we take a molecule of water,
we have to have
this free electron pair at oxygen,
to cause a so-called nucleophilic reaction
with this phosphorus from the phosphate group.
If this happens, this link is created.
Then these electrons can go to that oxygen,
which gives him a negative charge.
Now you can say, "Okay, that seems logical."
But do not forget that the electrons are negative
and are surrounded by these negative charges.
They have to overcome their approach.
Attacking these negative charges
want to repel, they must overcome this repulsion.
This is overcome by
a class of enzymes called ATPase.
Remember these enzymes
are large protein complexes and the ATP molecule can be
connect to the exact place in the enzyme.
They try to surround the ATP molecule
with positive ions.
Let's say there is a positive ion here,
he can "distract" these electrons as long as the water
performs the nucleophilic response.
Water will not have to worry about these electrons here.
There may be a positive ion here as well.
And remember, if we imagine the situation in three dimensions,
this thing has embraced the ATP molecule
from different countries, this is the ATFase.
So if we have an enzyme here,
we will lower the activating energy
and it will look like this.
Consequently, the reaction will be possible.
The reaction does not take place,
when we do not have an enzyme,
because we have this hill.
But if we have enzymes, they will
allow the reaction to take place.
Then this attacks this, this relationship is formed and you are saying,
"We have another hydrogen here."
"We have another hydrogen."
But it can be picked up by another water molecule
and to become a hydroxone ion. Exactly
is actually happening.
Then this oxygen takes this electron pair
and gets a negative charge. Finally, we have,
a truncated phosphate group,
ADP and energy release.
Generally, we would not want this reaction to release energy
no reason.
Most ATFas will use
the energy released in this reaction to phosphorylate the molecule.
In this case we can assume that this one
hydroxide is phosphorylated,
but many different molecules can be phosphorylated.
Or the conformation of this ATPase may change,
to start doing another kind of job.
For example, to carry molecules against their concentration
or electrochemical gradient.
We do not just want to release energy.
Sometimes it can happen if we want to
to generate heat but in most cases
we want to do some work useful for cells.
I hope this video helped you
to better understand the ATP and the reaction
of hydrolysis.
It is called hydrolysis because, as in this example,
water is used to decompose ATP
or for the cleavage of one of its phosphate groups.